[Música]
eu agradeço a oportunidade muito bom dia
bom planejar com a paisagem do conflito
há congruência nós temos uma questão
séria no brasil 85% a nossa população
mora nas cidades ea gente pode pensar
que isso não foi planejado mas não se
engane muitos processos de planejamento
acontecem
o problema é como eles acontecem eu
mostro para vocês
o programa minha casa minha vida um
grande processo de planejamento só que a
questão aqui é que o processo de
planejamento ele focou muito nas
questões da habitação do teto sobre a
cabeça das pessoas
a ciência de um modo geral pra evoluir
como evoluirão elas acabaram por é se
especializar e a especialização tem um
ônus e um bônus
o bônus é que se especializando elas
evoluíram com muito mais rapidez
o ônus é que nesse processo de
especialização elas perderam a
complexidade elas perderam a capacidade
de ver as coisas nas suas localidades
no que diz respeito às idades isso é uma
questão muito séria por exemplo esse é o
minhocão em são paulo ele é fruto de uma
época em que se planejou uma questão
relacionada à circulação a tal tac era
questão de circular que circular era
preciso mas o problema é que isso não
levou em conta muitas coisas que
aconteciam ao redor desse lugar certo
então a minha perspectiva que é pensar
que a paisagem pode ser um lugar onde
diferente saber e se encontram a
paisagem se lugar profico que encontra
não apenas as questões físicas do
território da geografia física os rios a
vegetação o relevo os ventos mas também
contra as questões sociais
as questões de cultura de patrimônio de
memória e desenvolvimento também porque
cidade sãs e belas são cidades onde o
investimento também se interessa muito
mais o meu campo a deeper tease que a
questão da arquitetura da paisagem que
em outros países é uma graduação em
separado mas no brasil participa da
arquitetura e do urbanismo como uma
chave
ela quer justamente construir a
convergência entre as questões da
natureza e as questões do artifício da
cultura que é o que está representado aí
a direita e isso esse campo disciplinar
em um campo disciplinar que tem uma
história por exemplo em 1901 fundo
acirrada do primeiro com o primeiro
curso de arquitetura da paisagem mas a
idéia da arquitetura da paisagem é muito
anterior ou seja o pac é projeto de
frederick 11 e é o pai do meu campo
disciplinar esse sujeito teve uma
epifania quando foi visitar a inglaterra
encontrou os primeiros parques e chegou
à conclusão que parece ser uma coisa
muito importante para a cidade terem e
eu pergunto a vocês por que um pai que é
importante apenas para a gente passe a
fé é importante por isso mas é
importante também porque ele soma duas
coisas fundamentais para o meio campo
disciplinar que a associação das
questões de infraestrutura da cidade
drenagem renovação de ar é a questão da
temperatura e as questões sociais a
questão do encontro a questão do lazer
ea questão da saúde que são muito
importantes
só que o onze de lhe deu o pulo do gato
em boston onde a professora ivone foi
estudar porque gosta é uma cidade
fantástica e maravilhosa porque ela tem
um sistema de parques muito interessante
que muito pouca gente sabe foi gerado
por ano o mistério na viragem do século
19 para o século 20 e que tinha uma
questão fundamental boston estava
perdido de doenças justamente ocasionada
pela água
ele ele pensou todo um sistema de
drenagem baseado no fluxo das marés que
passaram esgotar essa água suja para o
mar e salvou a cidade das suas doenças
boston é hoje o que é porque há um
determinado tempo a sua população e os
seus gestores acreditaram que pudesse
ser diferente
olha só e ele fez isso de um jeito muito
interessante porque ele já tinha lhe a
presença de uma água salobra então
quando ele vai fazer boston ele não está
pensando no mesmo registro estético do
central park
ele está pensando em algo que é
construído com a realidade então o meu
campo disciplinar nunca deixou de ter o
fenômeno nas suas questões
eu mostro agora para vocês essa cidade
que nós adotamos há muito tempo e que
mora no nosso coração são carlos está no
estado de são paulo e no estado de são
paulo o que vocês estão vendo são duas
manchas a mancha de fato ocupada ea
mancha que está por organizar e aí mora
um uma questão muito importante como se
quer planejar essa cidade
qual é a nossa relação por exemplo com
as águas estão vendo aí nós moramos no
privilégio nós não tomamos água servida
de nenhuma outra cidade que significa
ninguém aqui toma esgoto de outra cidade
atualmente tratado toda a água que é
capturada no próprio município e no
lençol aqüífero ou seja isso é ouro puro
ea gente tem que não só valorizar mas
nos tornarmos um exemplo ou seja não é
só que o capital da tecnologia é a
capital do privilégio ambiental também
só que isso não está sendo construído ao
longo do tempo de um modo a digamos
inteligente e eu vou tentar explicitar
isso pra vocês eu participo do gpu que é
um grupo de planejamento a partir dos
parques urbanos são é uma atividade
voluntária que me une a professora
renata burro peres da federal e que tem
o professor tundisi que está à frente da
secretaria o nosso é padrinho digamos
assim porque ele nos fomentou esse grupo
existe os estudantes estão conosco e
vários profissionais é um grupo
interdisciplinar
nós temos a participação de biólogos
ecólogos geógrafos estamos construindo
isso que vocês vão ver que eu chamo de
cartografia complexa
vejam eu estou juntando aqui a
hidrografia de são carlos
isso aqui é uma cartografia dos espaços
livres e de recreio está gravado no
nosso plano diretor
isso é terra pública certo muitas vezes
com qualificação muitas vezes sem
qualificação
isso aqui é são os parques públicos que
foram gravados que foram objeto de um
decreto em janeiro de 2017 saibam que
eles existem no papel mas não existem de
fato em nossa tarefa é justamente
colocar isso dentro de um sistema ou
seja a nossa pretensão é fazer com que
tudo isso talvez um dia
seja realidade na cidade de são carlos
isso que vocês estão vendo são as áreas
de especial interesse ambiental
elas também estão gravadas e essa
gravação ela tem a ver com a necessidade
legal de deixar essas terras ou é sem a
o processo de urbanização acontecendo
sobre elas ou ela se ela tenham elas têm
um papel ambiental importante quando eu
amo todas essas cartografias eu tenho
uma prima o primeiro desenho que esse
desenho aqui é um desenho das potenciais
áreas de intervenção ou de projeto
design uma das traduções da palavra
design é projeto certo
agora vejam do planejamento que é quando
eu ainda estou usando isso seja uma
perspectiva de visão de topo de sobrevoo
como a cartografia que eu chamo de fria
eu tenho um segundo movimento que está
indo na direção do projeto e o projeto é
o desenho do cotidiano é o desenho por
exemplo do kartódromo é o desenho de
pacs como eles são na cidade
esse trânsito de escalas que vai do
processo de planejamento urbanismo
ataque até o processo de projeto que é
onde o arquiteto o desenhador urbano
está ou paisagista eu tenho um trânsito
de escalas e eu queria dizer a vocês que
o grupo esse grupo do qual participo e
todos os alunos e profissionais que
estão juntos estão empenhados em fazer
isso acontecer eu mostro um exemplo que
já foi feito apenas fazendo um pequeno
parêntese para vocês verem esse acordo a
grafia mais antiga que eu tenho da
cidade de são carlos
como vocês podem ver foi um plano
diligentemente feito da de cima para
baixo de norte a sul de leste a oeste
uma cartografia de grade colocada num
relevo como desse tipo o que acontece
aqui e aí eu volto pega um ganchinho
daqui do começo da minha fala né
dentro das áreas de especialização as
pessoas que pensaram drenagem durante
muito tempo pensaram drenagem de um
jeito muito muito muito objetivo a água
vai do meio fio para a boca de lobo da
boca de lobo para os canos às vezes as
galerias e direto para o rio
isso é uma questão é que
contemporaneamente pode ser muito melhor
trabalhada certo quando eu falo
os parques eu penso também num sistema
de drenagem de microdrenagem muito mais
sofisticado e que ali espaços livres
bacanas as praças as ruas com
possibilidade de drenagem anterior da
gente chegar no ponto mais baixo
então vejam como todas essas coisas
vão-se juntando eu mostro para vocês
também que esse fenômeno por exemplo de
construção de uma cidade que foi ao
partir do passar dos tempos se
impermeabilizando muito
é uma questão de época e só que hoje a
gente precisa pensar fora da caixa e
pensar fora da caixa significa pegar
todas as caixas e misturá los
olha lá o processo de canonização de são
carlos e a resposta porque a gente
construiu as enchentes porque à época
esse era a melhor solução só que isso
aqui é algo que se construiu a enchente
não é culpa do rio nós ocupamos as
vazias
portanto a gente só tem uma resposta
quanto mais a cidade cresce mas ela
sempre me a brisa e mais o aumento a a
mancha de inundação
só que eu possa agregar a questões muito
interessantes nesse processo de criação
de pacs
essa é a enchente de 2018 2015
me contem pense um pouco sobre isso
alguém já colocou na ponta do lápis
quanto já se perdeu se a questão for
econômica em toda essa sucessão de
enchentes que aconteceu desde aquelas
fotos antigas até essa pois bem mostra
vocês então como é que esse processo se
faça é um processo que escolhe alguns
quadrantes
eu tô ali em cima na federal e aqui do
lado na direção do campus 2 aquela
mancha vai ser estudada em termos de uso
se é comércio ela vai ser estudado em
termos de densidade ou seja estou indo
na direção do projeto
e aí esse projeto ele vai estar
justamente entre o kartódromo e o câmbio
e essa área aqui daqui até aqui certo e
vocês vão ver agora que é uma área
suscetível já nos dias de hoje há
grandes enchentes
essa é uma chuva de uma hora que causou
extra
essa esse pac ele foi feito por uma ong
uma organização é 100 é uma associação
da comunidade bota ap portanto e esse
pessoal que hoje em dia amou cip está
tentando justamente um futuro diferente
para esse lugar
então imaginem que dentro daquela grande
cartografia eu escolhi uma bacia
hidrográfica aponta um lugar e faço esse
projeto esse projeto agrega questões que
estão ligadas a uma ciclovia essa
ciclovia uma ciclovia de passeio que
anda em volta do kartódromo mas ela pode
se conectar grande ciclovia
todos esses lugares que vocês estão
vendo em laranja são lugares que agora
estão numerados junto com a ciclovia que
vão receber intervenções
a questão aqui é e do lugar mais
naturalizado à esquerda em cima até o
mais artificioso que é o kartódromo
a idéia é que a água que possa ser
visitada olhada e que a população crie
justamente uma afetividade pela água que
a gente consiga compreender que a água
não é só algo que é um desastre mas é
algo que faz parte da nossa vida
a questão aqui é que essas esses lugares
de mitigação que são esses lugares que
foram enchidos net cheios de água eles
não são o melhor lugar mas foram os
possíveis passa agora algumas imagens
pra vocês
o kartódromo eu já conversei com quem
fez esse projeto eles toparam fazer esse
tipo de alteração sé
aqui é aquela praça à direita aquela
praça da descida do cno que também pode
ser usado hoje em dia é só um
estacionamento de carros não é e aí eu
tenho esses lugares sem água e com a
água
o próprio kartódromo sem água e com a
água e aí esses lugares eles vão
justamente funcionando como essas
estruturas em que eu vou retendo a água
os cálculos foram feitos eu tenho um
time muito essa é a sede da amor que
também vai ter ali uma estrutura ao
básico das questões de drenagem é você
conseguir fazer essa aqui é na altura da
república vazio onde tem uma
transposição e aqui vocês têm um momento
em que você pode ver a
o que eu mencionava era justamente essa
idéia de que você precisa diminuir a
velocidade da água até ela chegar no
ponto mais baixo você tem que criar
oportunidades dela percolar e você tem
que criar um lugar de encontro e lazer
da população para que ela possa ver essa
água e viver um outro tipo de vida que
está ligado justamente a questão isso
aqui é no meio do bosque do cambuí onde
essa organização já faz várias vivências
ambientais
a gente pensou pra eles em um mobiliário
quando as crianças pudessem se encontrar
os adultos e tudo mais
vejam bem agora tentando reunir todos os
pontos para vocês a entenderem porque eu
sou uma defensora do pensar fora da
caixinha e pensar com a paisagem como um
elemento aonde todos os saberes podem se
encontrar ea gente construir um futuro
comum em outro registro
imaginem que eu converso com as pessoas
da saúde e que elas possam participar
desse processo de projeto com as pessoas
da educação com as pessoas por exemplo
da cultura e do lazer
percebam que toda essa cartografar ação
ela pode gerar espaços muito ricos
ligados à população de são carlos retê
água renovar os ares e fazer de fato uma
revolução muito obrigado
[Música]